on se prépare en avance attention
on mord pas
alors attention c'est parti
les mecs il y a une musique de ouf par
contre il faut pas tirer sur Benjamin
sur tes yeux on sait jamais
il a pas trop de trucs à protéger et
bien c'est pas comme si il avait les
yeux grand ouvert
c'est pas non plus un poisson
pas non plus des yeux de poisson
[Rires]
oh mais ils sont très forts ils sont
très forts tombés je pense ouais
allez merci Salut
boire
allez vas-y si vous pouvez préparer
votre arc et vos flèches avant d'arriver
parce qu'on va pas rester 2h ici à faire
les courses merci on a gagné
allez allez vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y
vas-y vas-y vas-y vas-y allez vas-y moi
je le sens grave par contre je suis mort
Raymond c'est pas la première fois qu'on
me le dit on me l'a dit au Rambo
tu as déjà fait du tir à l'arc hein pas
mal il y avait la puissance mais pas la
précision
pour l'instant tout se passe bien c'est
Valérie un café
merci gilberté deuxième tour ou pas chef
je vais sélectionner les trois meilleurs
pour un deuxième tour
à Valérie Kelly pour l'instant vas-y et
Raymond
Géraldine merci je regarde un petit peu
l'heure parce qu'on a quand même des
choses à faire
parce que ce soit gros prime stagiaire
on a des images YouTube
[Rires]
attention Raymond tu mensonge
oh
en dernier et après j'aurai j'aurais six
flèches
[Rires]
j'aurai donc si allez on y va
y arriver
tu as fait tous les les clubs et tout
mais il était pas géotir alors
attention tu mens voilà il bande le
maximum la première fois qu'on me le dit
plus fort vous avez
passé
ils m'ont mis à l'enversé
vous inquiétez pas c'est la faute de
personne ça va partir maintenant
les mecs forts
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on fera toutes les flèches jusqu'à ce
que ça passe pas
le temps qu'il faudra
ça va
tout mis dedans change d'arcs c'est bien
suspense
[Rires]
je ne peux pas lancer la pub avant 7h
voilà
sinon je prends une amende du CSA donc
je vais mettre le temps qu'il faudra
pour mettre cette de flèche dans
cette team
bordel de merde
parce qu'il faut que tu tiens
le vert et tire avec le noir
t'inquiète pas
il a fini deuxième à Zarzis avec
celui-là
le mec il est
allez on va faire un truc maintenant
pour l'été spectateurs allez on va dire
il reste trois flèche allez allez
minutes on tiendra jamais
m'envoyer déjà sur le plateau et je vais
aller directement sur le plateau après
avoir fait tomber Castaldi ok il me
restera trois flèches ok d'accord et une
gratuite qu'est-ce qu'il y a
voilà
je suis allergique là j'ai tapé c'est
pas qui je sais pas qui monsieur
il est pas dans la ville
la dernière
fois
c'est la dernière j'ai aimé aussi bon
quand il a la pression
[Applaudissements]